des drapeaux noirs dans les rues de
jérusalem symbole de la menace qui plane
sur la démocratie israélienne près d'un
millier d'israéliens ont manifesté ce
week end contre l'accord de coalition
conclu entre le premier ministre
israélien benyamin netanyahou et son
rival benny ganz coronavirus oblige les
protestataires se sont rassemblés dans
la rue en observant les mesures de
distanciation physique et en arborant
des masques portant l'inscription
ministre du crime
le mouvement pour un gouvernement de
qualité en israël manifestent contre
l'accord de coalition corrompus qui a
été signé nous serons à la cour suprême
dans l'espoir qu'elle annule la
nomination de benyamin nétanyahou en
raison de ces différentes inculpation
nous avons grandi avec les valeurs de la
démocratie et j'éduque méfie de la même
manière je vois l'état se dégrader
depuis des années et toutes ces
précieuses institutions corrompues et je
ne laisserai pas mes fille grandir dans
un pays différent de celui dans lequel
j'ai grandi alors benyamin netanyhou
pourra type dirigées ou non le prochain
gouvernement
malgré son inculpation pour corruption
c'est la question à laquelle doivent
répondre les onze juges de la cour
suprême israélienne
l'accord prévoit que netanyahu sera
premier ministre pendant les 18 premiers
mois avant de passer la main benny gantz
pour une période équivalente les
portefeuilles ministériels seront
répartis équitablement entre les deux
camps les juges ont jusqu'à jeudi pour
entendre vip l'un déposé par des groupes
de défense des droits civiques pour
décider si cet accord entre le likoud et
carole lavallée légal nous avons reçu un
recours qui se lèvent question juridique
principal qui sont allés battre l'un des
problèmes concernent la nomination d'un
membre de la crise m votre laquelle
certaines accusations ont été portées
sous la formation d'un gouvernement berg
à s'activer au cours concerne cette
question
le deuxième problème concerne la
validité de l'accord de coalition signé
le 20 avril 2020 entre le vif
et carole la vanne pour former le 35e
gouvernement si la haute cour lui dans
son feu vert
l'accord permettra la mise en place du
premier gouvernement élu au terme de
trois scrutins et ainsi mettre fin à la
plus longue crise politique que le pays
ait connu